that's my king understanding do the  video in this song  of you i'll take this guys okay if you  are somewhere and you have the  opportunity to spend the money to get  you something good spend the money i was  in africa one time really i really used  to buy a human skull right it was 600. i  don't spend the money and ended up  getting like a candle every time i  light that candle all i think of is just  how cheap i was and how cool it would  have been to have the skull now do we  think that having a human skull in the  house would be a good thing though in  hindsight oh hold on a second  hold on wait a second where i'm from  people have all kind of they have all  kind of people bury their family in the  in the yard we have you know stuff  hold on no 20 feet away that is nothing  like what this [ __ ] guy is asking  you're talking about buying a human  head  okay  and he's not for a couple like you saw  not a good feeling like you're a bad guy  in a james bond movie